Koje ratne zločine nam
je dozvoljeno da žalimo?
Sve.
Ne, Tom.
Samo one koje
zanimaju Zapadne medije.
To je tačno.
Probajte ovo da pogodite:
Imamo dva filma o stravičnim
istorijskim događajima
koji su se dogodili na
manje-više istom prostoru.
Jedan film, “Dara iz Jasenovca”,
vodi nas u II svetski rat,
kada je jedan fašistički
režim na Balkanu
ubio stotine hiljada
Srba, Jevreja i drugih.
Drugi film, „Quo Vadis,
Aida?“, bavi se devedesetima,
odnosno ubistvom
hiljada ljudi u ratnoj enklavi.
I koji od ova dva filma
je „odobren“ od strane
„Variety“ magazina, a koji nije?
Ako ste pogađali da je
„Variety“ pustio suzu povodom
filma o Holokaustu
– pogrešili ste.
Očigledno je reč i o
pogrešnom Holokaustu –
onaj balkanski se „ne računa“.
„Variety“ je napisao
surovu kritiku tvrdeći da je
„Dara iz Jasenovca“, igrani
film o borbi jedne devojčice
da preživi strahote
koncentracionog logora Jasenovac,
najvećeg u fašističkoj
marionetskoj Hrvatskoj,
„tanko prerušena propaganda“.
Iako je scenario filma zasnovan
na svedočenjima preživelih,
„Variety“ je odlučio
da je film anti-hrvatski
i da stvara razdor između
Srbije i njenih komšija.
U filmu je naglašeno
da su zlodela činili fašisti,
a ne Hrvati kao nacija,
ali „Variety“ to ne zanima.
S druge strane, „Quo
Vadis, Aida?“, film o
bosanskom prevodiocu
za UN rastrzanom između
poslovnih obaveza i
porodice dok izbija rat,
dobio je sve same
pohvale od „Variety“
i opisan je kao „mučno,
vitalno prepričavanje
masakra u Srebrenici
1995. godine“.
Dovoljno je da pogledate
2-minutni trejler filma
da primetite koliko puta
napadaju Srbe kao naciju.
Srpska, srpskoj,
srpskome,
srpske, Srbi, Srbi…
Ubiće ih Srbi ako ih nađu.
Ubiće i mene.
Ipak, nema “anti-srpskih”
etiketa od “Variety”.
Slično, “LA Times” je lepo
pisao o “Quo Vadis, Aida?”,
ali je osudio “Daru
iz Jasenovca” kao
“ogoljeno nativističku
i manipulativnu.”
Potpuno licemerje.
I čemu sad dvostruki aršini?
Pa, 1990-ih je bilo
nekoliko ratova na Balkanu,
a Zapad je odlučio da
su Srbi koji su se borili
u Hrvatskoj i Bosni
bili „loši momci“.
Oni su apsolutni
agresori i zločinci.
I dok su sve
strane činile zločine,
Zapadno svrstavanje sa
hrvatskim i bosanskim snagama
značilo je da glavni
mediji smeju da pričaju
samo o srpskim zločinima.
A kad su Srbi žrtve?
Srećom, te tragedije su iza nas,
ali tragedija sa kojom
se suočavamo sada jeste
politika koja podriva naša
osnovna ljudska osećanja –
da žalimo svaku ratnu
žrtvu bez stavljanja
etničkih predznaka
na bilo koji zločin.
Sram vas bilo, „Variety“.
Sram vas bilo, „LA Times“.
Povucite svoje sramotne kritike
i izostavite iz ovoga
svoju prljavu politiku.